[Music]
they're edgy rebellious and popular I
speak is onstage in the design for the
final concert of their Russia tour the
song sad [ __ ] is clearly an audience
favorite here it's an anthem against
Authority elitism and conformism songs
like this one have made the authorities
and Russia suspicious of I speak the
band say they shut down more than half
of their concerts on their recent Russia
tour the musicians were searched in
questions several times it felt
completely surreal we sing a few songs
and the Secret Service's chase us
through the whole city yes some of our
songs do have a political message but
the political stuff is such a small
percentage of our work so you think to
yourself what would happen if we were
actually a political group they wouldn't
let us perform at all I pour kerosene
into my eyes the whole of Russia is
watching me let it all burn lyrics and
videos like this one are intentionally
provocative here the duo poses in front
of the seed of the Russian government
and on the shoulders of the riot police
I speak isn't the only young group that
has had problems with the authorities
last year over 40 concerts were canceled
it's a crackdown that has shaken the
Russian music scene but also created a
huge sense of solidarity at the end of
2018
dozens of musicians took to the stage in
Moscow to protest against the tough
stance of the Kremlin these absurd
things can happen to other musicians
they can easily happen to any of us
lightly there seems to be an unspoken
rule for musicians if you so much as
touch on politics you'll have problems
this situation would make any musician
want to write about it it politicizes
people who otherwise wouldn't be
interested in political protests at all
lad amir Putin seems to have understood
that as well and has signal
a change in the kremlin strategy the
russian president wants his
administration to come up with new plans
to support youth culture by September
round and other modern music is based on
three pillars sex drugs and protesting
but I just know what the drugs are our
biggest concern of course miss buck
would they clearly lead to a degradation
of the entire society if this music is
impossible to stop then we will have to
lead and direct it properly on the prowl
yet
however Putin tries to lead and direct
observers say the Kremlin will do all in
its power to ensure the discontent
doesn't turn into a protest movement
what we've seen so far is an attempt by
the Kremlin to label anything they don't
understand as non-existent useless and
wrong but now the main thing for them is
to re-establish communication with young
people to understand what they want and
how to deal with that it is on the
problems the group had with the police
has led some parents to accompany their
kids to the concert most of the fans
here say they identify with I speaks
lyrics they're often about a sense of
hopelessness
I can really relate to this music I
think it reflects my reality here I know
exactly what they mean the fact that the
government is cracking down on this
group doesn't solve the problems they're
singing about it could lead to protests
the band can clearly relate to the
worries and realities of their young
fans many of them say they don't feel
the Kremlin understands them anymore at
all the government has decided to
correct youth culture to somehow bend it
back into its old shape but the process
can't be stopped anymore and we
certainly won't censor ourselves now we
want to be even harsher more radical and
interesting you can't ban music the fans
chant in between songs at the concert
I speaks dark and sarcastic music has
clearly touched a nerve with young
Russians and their difficulties with the
authorities have gotten them a lot of
publicity
instead of silencing them it has made
them one of the voices of a new
generation the Kremlin is now pushing to
connect with